nama saya Paul senang Birkenau man I've
been studying Indonesian for six months
and 17 days and I still can't introduce
myself what's going on here hi guys this
is Paul today I want to talk to you
about one of the most important elements
of learning a language of studying a
language and that is consistency this is
one of my mottos consistency is king if
you've read my blog or something you've
heard talk to me about languages you
probably heard me say that slogan that
motto consistency is king the people who
really get good at languages are the
people who study consistently they study
every day come hell or high water they
don't find excuses to skip their
studying the people who don't really
learn as much the people who don't get
that good the people who learn just a
bit those are the people who just study
whenever they feel like it the people
who don't study consistently they just
study based on a whim so I like to think
about consistency in a couple of ways
the first way is like this your language
ability is like a bucket with a small
hole in the bottom right so the water
the liquid inside is your language
ability and if you stop studying then
there's a slow leak and your ability
will slowly diminish if you don't top up
the bucket but if you top up the bucket
every day by studying them you can
maintain the level consistently you can
maintain a certain level or even raise
the level of the liquid inside the
bucket but it's when you stop studying
when you're not consistent then
gradually day by day each day a little
bit of the liquid leaks out at the
bottom and the level diminishes so
that's like your language ability going
down so if you've ever studied a
language for a couple months and then
you took a few weeks off like maybe you
lost motivation or whatever then you
came back to it you probably noticed if
you probably felt that you had lost the
majority of what you had learned right
so that's because you had
little bit of liquid in the bucket and
then it gradually mostly leaked out it
was probably some residue in there a few
drops but you probably lost a lot of the
meat of what you had learned so it's one
one example you if you've ever been a
couple years into studying a language
like a year or two and then you took a
few weeks off you probably noticed that
your level had diminished a bit probably
it had gone down but you probably didn't
feel like you would lost most of what
you'd learned because it's that gradual
diminishment is that gradual lowering of
the level it's a slow leak so the more
of a beginner you are the more of your
ability you will lose if you're not
consistent but the way to always
maintain your level and to keep
increasing it is to be consistent and
top up the bucket every day so that's
one way I like to think about your
consistency and studying the other way I
like to think about it is in terms of
investing when you invest money over
time when you do it consistently you can
gain compound interest right that means
that you make interest on the money that
you invest but then you make interest on
the interest as well this is similar to
a phenomena that I've noticed when
studying consistently when you study
everyday consistently and you don't take
days off you're learning kind of takes
on a life of its own and you end up
learning more than you would expect from
the amount you're studying right that's
partly because your brain is learning in
the off time when you're not studying
it's kind of processing things in the
background all day but basically if you
are consistent then you can get your
you're learning to a sort of critical
mass where it starts to take on a life
of its own you learn more than you would
have if you had studied that same number
of days but with breaks in between so
it's really important to to always keep
investing on a daily basis
investing regularly so that you can get
that compounding effect in your learning
okay so that's another way I like to
think about it so there's the the bucket
with the hole in the bottom but then
there's compounding interest there's
those two ways
so the most important point is study
everyday be consistent also put in a
certain amount of time every day try to
commit as much time to it as you can but
more important than that is to do it
consistently every day how do you be
consistent that's the question that
remains a lot of people intend to be
consistent but they end up taking a lot
of time often being inconsistent so
those people usually are taking action
based on how they feel at the moment I
wake up in the morning and I think on
tired today screw it I just won't study
today they're basing their action on the
feeling of that moment which is
something you can't really control I
mean the way you feel depends on all
sorts of different factors out of your
control depends on maybe what you ate
yesterday it depends on the weather it
depends on how well you slept it depends
on stress at work all these things so
you can't really control it that easily
unless you're always monitoring all
those things really closely so the way
to the way to take action should be
based on your vision for your outcome
what you want to get out of learning
that language and also based on just a
commitment a commitment to achieving
that outcome achieving that vision so
let's say you want to be a French
English translator that's your dream so
you have to have that vision in mind for
the future that goal what will that look
like and then a commitment to work hard
every day to achieve that right so then
in that case if you have that vision and
commitment when you wake up in the
morning and you're tired or you're
hungover or whatever then you will just
tell yourself okay I don't feel like it
today but I have that vision and the
commitment so I'm going to do it anyway
because it's not based on the feeling so
that's how you that's how you can be
consistent is by doing that all right
don't let it be based on a feeling a
feeling is changing by the moment it's
out of your control base it on your
vision and commitment alright hope
that's helpful thank you very much for
listening and talk to you again